[Music]
brooklyn
in the house yes whoa
tonight's subject is on the topic of
morality
and all the ways that science might or
might not
inform our future judgments regarding it
and we
have a panel specifically tuned for that
purpose
people of high and low moral stature
just
[Laughter]
let me first introduce a comedian
michael ian black michael
come on out
not only a comedian an actor a director
we've been seeing the jim gaffigan show
comedy central's another period and
netflix we had a wet summer white hot
american summer wet hot american summer
close enough
i'd also like to introduce the founding
editor and publisher of skeptics
magazine michael shermer michael schumer
come on out michael
hey then excellent all right
thank you michael shermer is author of
the moral arc how science and reason
lead humanity towards truth justice and
freedom
audacious of you to do such a thing who
else do we have here
because not all morality perhaps comes
from
rational thought perhaps it comes from
religious thought
and we'll bring out father james martin
a jesuit priest
father martin come on out
hello he's actually the best-selling
author
of a jesus pilgrimage is that did i get
that name right
the name of that is that right uh jesus
a pilgrimage this is a pilgrimage
and most recently building a bridge and
this is subtitled how the catholic
church
and the lgbt community can enter into a
relationship of reflection
compassion and sensitivity whoa where'd
this come from
will you be excommunicated tomorrow for
having done this uh depends what i say
tonight okay
excellent how many seats we have left
one seat left join me in giving a warm
a warm brooklyn welcome to whoopi
goldberg
whoopee where is she hey
all right let's do this star talk live
kings theater brooklyn in the house
so uh michael you've you're this is not
your first
rodeo with books my third round third
rodeo third rodeo
uh what is your sense of
uh the origins of what is right and
wrong do you have some
thoughts about that i do um i think
since
you're a physicist and you have the best
selling physics book of all time
i'd start with physics for the moment
i'm going to start with physics
the second law of thermodynamics entropy
the universe is running down
everything dissolves hot things get cold
uh organisms wear out and so forth so
the first
second law of thermodynamics is the
first law of life
which is to push back against entropy
that is to go up
the energy gradient by doing things with
your cells
by replicating by flourishing by
consuming
energy and so forth okay so the most
selfish thing you could do
would be to hoard all the resources you
can be selfish this selfish gene kind of
thinking
but the problem with that is that if you
live in a social community
everybody else who acts like that it's
not going to work it's going to fall
apart if
you're super selfish and i'm super
selfish and if we're just hoarding
resources from each other this is going
to dissolve so
the most selfish thing i can do at times
that could dissolve into
war and death and bloodshed it's
happened simply into ein rand novels
yes that's a dystopian atlas right it's
a it's true
well it's sort of a hobbes you know
nasty brutish and short
so part of life is like that but
sometimes the most selfish thing you can
do
is to be cooperative altruistic helpful
nice be a good friend
be a reliable respectful person with a
good reputation because that way
when you help somebody when they're in
need when your time comes when you need
help
then they're more likely to help you now
it's not a it's not a cold calculation
like
i'm going to trick you into into
thinking i'm nice and then i'm going to
stab you in the back once i get your
resources no because you'll know
that i'm faking because we're our brains
are fine-tuned to notice when people are
lying
or people are dissembling or where
they're narcissistic in a
in a inauthentic way and so
it's not enough to say i'm not talking
about any no no one here no no one here
the brains aren't fine too enough to
tell when someone's narcissistic
it's those people in california no no
that's where i'm from no
um no it's not enough to fake being a
nice person you actually have to
be a nice person and not in my
experience
okay there's our one yeah okay
we have picked out the psychopath on the
panel
we found him it's because it's about one
out of uh three out of a hundred or so
anyway
uh so my argument about a hundred
i know three out of 100 people are
psychopaths yeah about three out of a
hundred well
men three out of three out of 100 men
sure and then
i could have told you that
all right oh it's true i'm sorry to say
uh okay so you're describing something
that is evolutionarily pre-selected for
our own survival
that's right so it's not enough to fake
being a good person you actually have to
feel it you have to have the
genuine moral emotions of
of wanting to help and feeling good
about that now it's not to say that
human nature is we're all good
because we have a dark side we have our
inner demons and our better angels in
competition so the whole point
of structuring a civil society in a way
is to nudge
the incentives to get people to be nicer
and
knock back those super selfish
tendencies and it's a constant
tug and pull of what we should do in
this particular community or society or
whatever to get people to be nicer
so you're saying to be moral
is uh for our own collective survival
and that is sort of self-selecting and
your survival i mean it's better for you
okay you may okay you maybe could
can benefit by by by being super selfish
and
and and betraying your friends and so on
yes those
people can get away with it but if too
many of us act like that
the whole system falls apart so we've
evolved the propensity where most people
most of the time are nice wait so uh
what
number like in a culture like in a
society what's the number of like
[ __ ] that can handle this that's
right
the threshold yeah what's the [ __ ]
threshold
it's about really there's studies on
this it's about it's about
twenty percent about twenty one percent
well if you go out from
you know the backstabbing psychopaths
out to
just the night not necessarily someone
who'll eat your donut when you turn
around
yeah that that's about like one out of
five but those people
most of those 20 are are reformable you
can
in other words if you catch if you put a
mirror in front of the donut
uh stand there at the company and
there's two donuts
okay
so father
father uh jesuit father
um another big laugh line
first uh this is not your first time on
star talk
i am very happy to be back you you you
you came back i thank you for coming
back thank you for inviting me okay
yes and
uh earlier we wanted to get cozy with
you uh call you jesuit james
that kind of sound like jesse james
jesuit james whatever you want it's your
show
so uh does uh
if you can first speak more broadly
about religion
certainly as manifested in a modern
american society and then perhaps
more specifically from the view of
catholicism does
does what um michael said
is that embraced as something that
god knows about and put in place or or
do you require some other deeper
infusion of understanding immorality in
religious thought
that's a great way of asking the
question um a lot of what
michael says makes sense to me and is
accepted and certainly signs
and faith there's no uh um sort of
conflict i think at least as a
for a catholic um you know for example
the idea that we would have certain
emotions that would lead us to do good
things i would
definitely agree with that and that
those emotions will ultimately lead to
the common good
we would say in the catholic church i
think the added
uh gloss i would put on that uh is that
um for us for a religious person those
no those notions and those emotions come
from god
and so i also agree that there are these
different forces pulling us apart and
pulling in different ways and we all
know that we have
sort of a selfish and selfless desires
and we can feel that tug of war
uh and what i would say is that the
desire to do good
is really uh god's voice within you
right i mean you don't hear voices but
you feel
this desire to to do something good and
and that's one way that you have of
helping other people and in a sense
carrying out god's will so that's and
what is that called that's called your
conscience basically and so
that's how i see it uh that god that the
moral law
is spoken to us uh through our
conscience and then
you know through reflection uh
throughout thousands of years of history
we have given
voice to that um you know in terms of
laws and the bible and things like that
you know the ten commandments are kind
of an expression of that
for that culture back then so yeah so i
mean i would agree with a lot of that
okay okay but the the so
what i'm curious about here is the um
there are many people who are not moral
so would you say that all the people who
are not moral and all that
which would include everyone who is
justifiably in prison
they as a community are without god
that's what you would i'd be forced to
conclude that based on your statement
so that you cannot say this
moral imperative is put into everyone by
god
it is put into some people and not
others by god well i would say that
actually god is with everyone right but
clearly not those in prison who
committed multiple murders well
there may be another bad guy inside just
one over their god conscience
just throwing out ideas no i mean
yeah i'll leave it up to jesus
uh we also have um we also have free
choice god gives us free will and so
those people
in jail who i still think god is with
and you know have have consciences and
souls and god loves them
um you don't think some of them god just
likes
you know what actually i think god likes
the more oh
i do well
no because that's true if you think
about i'm for the christian who does
jesus go to
jesus goes to the people who are seen as
in the society
sinful or on the outs and who is more on
the outs
than an inmate on death row right who is
more forgotten
and so i would say that this is the
person who god kind of goes out to first
and i believe scott also loves the nazis
there aren't they're
people like both sides people hate them
they are they are to quote to quote
james
on the outs yeah they're on the outs
it's almost 2020 and everyone is looking
at everything on their cell phones you
need your website to be perfect on any
mobile device
and wix automatically formats everything
from mobile
even lets you refine it for a perfect
experience
how cool is that head to the link in the
description
and start your site today that's wix.com
go slash star talk
la la la okay forget it so whoopee yes
you've you've been i'm on the outs with
everybody
all the time first let me let me be a
fan boy here for a minute
you're one of a dozen living humans who
have won
the grammy the emmy the oscar
and the tony award and still i work
every day
still you work still i work every day
it's a wonderful thing but you know you
still got it
you still gotta get up and go to work
and dance for your food so i'm just
fanboring a little bit there
so you've you've led what i have judged
to be
a very real even raw
uh life absorbing reality and
manifesting that in
the decisions you make for a greater
good
where do you where does your morality
come from how do you decide what's right
or wrong
well i
i judge it by my mother
okay because my mom
pretty much said look you can go over
there and rip those people off
but you can't be surprised when they
beat you to death with a baseball bat
now you can go and do it you can still
do it
but you have to take responsibility for
your choice which is what you're talking
about
you know if you if you subscribe to
the religious some religious thought you
know
the ideas that god is basically saying
listen
i'm not going to do for you i'll be here
if you need me but i'm not going to do
for you now not everybody wants to hear
that
because you you know you hear first the
story god got pissed at gomorrah look
what happened
right old testament there's a lot of
well there's a lot of
smite and [ __ ] you know it's just yeah
sorry father
he's here to forgive us all at the end
yes
it depends on on which book you're you
know
there's so many religions and so many
ideas so you have to at some point
make a decision what's going to work for
you
you know now sometimes people end up
killing people they don't mean to
but they did does that make him a
godless person i don't know
we'll have to ask dick cheney
[Laughter]
so michael yeah i didn't do it
back in 04 you wrote a book uh called
the science of good
and evil yeah why people cheat gossip
uh care share and follow the golden rule
yeah so
clicks right it's for clicks yeah yeah
that works
but let me i'm just trying to get to the
bottom of this yeah you spent the
opening remarks
saying that there's a force in our
culture
that leads people to be honest and moral
well in our nature
in our nature so whether that was sort
of genetically inbred evolutionarily
or imparted by god the point is it is
clear
that not everybody behaves this way so
let me hear a little bit more about that
20 percent
that can percolate up because in every
office environment we know people
who lie steal cheat yes and they take
the paper clips they don't pay for the
donut
but but the point of the mirror was if
you put a mirror in front of them
they're more likely to pay for the donut
they see
themselves and that reflects literally
their conscience so what what you're
doing with the mirrors is
is reminding them like whoopi's mother
don't forget to be a good girl
okay and so think of the moral sense
like a language
we all evolve the capacity to learn a
language everybody which language you
learn depends on which culture you grow
up in
so think of like a moral sense moral
emotions are like a language we all get
it just by dent of being human
which thing like the the capacity to
feel guilt everybody can feel guilt
not having except the three percent
except for the three percent yeah
they're they're guiltless but but but
but most of us uh
now what you feel guilty about
specifically depends on your culture
now catholics feel guilty about certain
things that protestants don't feel
guilty about or both
feel guilty about everything
am i approximately correct not this
[Laughter]
catholic
okay do you feel guilty about your
predecessors prosecuting galileo
yes i do okay
just have to get that off yeah well you
took it all the way back i took it all
the way back in the day galileo galileo
jesuit priest there you go but it wasn't
until 1992
that the pope forgave galileo back in 16
early 1600s
changed i'm still not over it
[Laughter]
so michael so what of the people who are
not just simply
passively or opportunistically cheaters
the people who are presumably not only
in the three percent who are
actively aggressive yes huge armies
yes to lay waste yeah are declared
enemies yeah
so the myth is that how do you the myth
is that they're not moral in fact
they're
overly moral they're uber moral they the
most homicides the majority of homicides
are moralistic in nature they're not
instrumental well i killed him to take
his rolex or his car
no it's the bastard scratched my car he
insulted me in front of my girlfriend he
cheated at cards
that's why mostly men cheated at cards
oh this used to be a thing in the you
know right in the wild west yeah
smith and wesson beats four aces so i
mean
there there are studies of of all these
guys on death row
like in the in i've studied the database
in the state of uh texas
they've executed five hundred and
forty-five people since and only
two were guilty was it i said and only
two were guilty
yeah well well a lot of them are yeah so
probably a good 10 to 15 percent didn't
do it
but a lot of them did do it and when you
ask them why'd you do it
they don't say because i'm a bastard or
an [ __ ] that you know it's like well
the guy cheated he she cheated on me or
he he stole my cup he insulted me in
front of my girlfriend this kind of
thing
in other words the the the murderer is
acts as in in a form of self-help
justice as judge
jury and executioner in one shot can i
ask a question
it seems like what you're saying is
morality is a narrative we tell
ourselves to justify
our actions so to flip that around you
would then say that
texas the state is acting morally by
killing these people and therefore
if you extrapolate further any state or
nation
which is basically what you said uh
tells themselves the narrative of they
are acting
morally to commit genocide that's right
so it's
but as a stepping back from that we go
well that's not moral behavior
so how do you so then it seems like
morality can be anything you say it is
as long as you tell yourself
you're doing the right thing yeah yeah
so great joke michael
he's hilarious you psychopaths they have
their moments
you know okay so here's what happens
with this here's the problem
um because there are bullies the problem
is people are killing each other that's
the problem yes yes yes
okay so yeah because of this 20
or so of free riders bullies [ __ ]
you have to stand up and fight back you
got to just you know just slap this guy
back you have to develop a reputation
you know you don't spit into the wind
you don't you know take you know
and so forth you gotta you gotta fight
back and that's the one way
like your mom said if you go steal that
they're going to punch you
okay kill her with a bat
and i believe she was talking about
robbing a baseball team
i grew up in new york individuals
all the way up to groups to states to
nations develop this
belief that comes from nature like you
got to fight back you got to stand up to
bullies
and free riders and people that steal
your stuff you got to stop them
all right so then this ends up getting
into this sort of just war theory when
is it okay to go to war
and the problem is is exactly what you
said um there's a new database i've just
been reading about in this book called
the internationalist 500
war um statements by nations this is why
we're going to war it's 500
different versions of why we should kill
these people and take their stuff
and it's all rationalization so
everybody that commits
a crime or an immoral act or whatever
they don't think they're doing that they
think they're doing good
but what's happened over the centuries
is that we've been adjusting that
rationalization to be less and less
hopefully violent aggressive justified
violence and more and more toward
international courts
the u.n the hague all these kinds of
international laws that said and this
really is just the last 50 years you
can't do that anymore war is illegal
and so to get around it because you've
noticed people have gotten around that
over the last
50 years but but the idea is first you
outlaw it like slavery you
outlaw it now it still goes on but then
you enforce the law and eventually it's
it stops and then we stop thinking about
it as an option
except that you know that sounds
really great but people get really
pissed off when they lose a war
they just they can't let it go
well if you think about germany and
japan i'm thinking about the us
oh you're talking about us civil war
and people can't let it go you know you
you're dealing with it
we're dealing with statues that were put
up in the 50s
yes well here's a yeah this is a perfect
example
okay the adjustment of our sensibilities
these used to be heroes these martial
statues
honoring military men that's just not
cool anymore and that's no no
the the statues that have gone up were
of the guys who actually broke the law
they were the you know a lot of the a
lot of those statues that went up
were what happened he said traitors
you okay all right they were trading
we'll take care of it thank you sir
you know we uh well let me ask let me
ask our
is there any sense that other animals
have
any sense of morality oh they did a
purely human thing no no no no
no other than penguins
that's right the most moral animal in
the world
that's what we need another penguin
movie yeah we didn't have enough
yeah uh we know that uh chimps and
bonobos uh
fight a lot and then they have makeup
sex afterwards so it's
it's usually the females that break up
the fights and you know and
smooth things over they have they have
all kinds of behavioral ways of calming
things down after
uh hostile interactions uh we know that
we've seen dolphins and whales
like push their wounded uh brothers and
sisters up to get air um
we know that elephants grieve you can
see dogs that feel
guilt grieve griez breathe what kind of
dogs that feel guilt like if they eat
too many snacks or they like yeah they
steal your stuff and they you know you
come in and go hey and they go you know
the tail goes down
but is that guilt or is that a fear of
punishment
or is that is or are those too
distinguishable i i was visiting some
folks house
and we left some cheese on the table and
went out for an hour it came back
and the cheese was gone it was a big
slab of cheese
and we said where where'd the cheese go
no one knew and then we all looked at
the dog
just just looked at the dog and the dog
cowered and went behind we didn't even
say anything
but if you did that yeah that was that
way
you didn't even but but guilt guilt
implies the ability to
uh correct if you did that 100 times
that dog would eat that [ __ ] cheese a
hundred times
until he tried to poop
it's is is god in a thieving dog soul
well there's a famous experiment by
franz duvall at emory university with
two capuchin monkeys
in side by side capuchin monkeys
these cute little they're like that yeah
yeah they're like yeah yeah just anyway
they're like i'm the only one who didn't
know what a capuchin monkey was
i didn't know but i felt like you had
already got a tiny brain little monkey
just tiny you know like 20 pounds
okay anyway so there's two of them side
by side in this cage translucent wall
they can see each other
and they've been trained to give a
pebble to the uh
experimenter who gives them a piece of
food in exchange so they just learn to
associate that
so the pebbles are like money for
exchange all right so
uh in comes the experimenter you can
watch this on youtube it's quite
hilarious so she gives
him a pebble and he gives it back to her
and she gives him a cucumber slice and
he's all excited oh boy he eats his
cucumber slices they like cucumbers
then the other one does the same thing
and she gives him a grape
now they like grapes even more because
you know who doesn't
and and so but but the first one now
sees that this one got a grape and he's
very excited like oh boy i'm gonna get a
grape and
he gets the pebble to her and she hands
him a cucumber and he goes
boom like this and then he's like
pounding on the cage and rattling the
cage while
he is pissed he he can clearly see
i did the same amount of work as that
guy and he got paid twice as much as and
that is not cool
whoa no they don't have language they
can't say you know i hereby protest and
i'm going to union
yeah but they got pooped right wait what
kind of monkey is it again
capuchin is there a capuchin bernie
sanders
that's right we're going to smooth out
the income equally yeah
so interesting so this is the
frustration
felt by not being compensated for the
same work exactly
right it's there and and we are
evolutionarily separated from these
capuchins by about 30 million years
so this goes way back in mammals
so it's a social social mammals that you
have to have a sense
of of right and wrong in order to get
along with your other fellow group
members so so
father is the does the catholic church
have some
definition of or operational discussion
a way to describe what is just as pure
evil well i'm evil in general as was
what distances you from god or an
act that that that itself distances you
from god and it's contrary to you know
what we would say
would be the moral law yeah but there's
different kinds of evil too so all right
so i'll
grant that but historically what we may
have judged to be evil
has evolved right so there are people
not blaming you for this but we can say
without hesitation
there are many people who justified
slavery
as the moral thing to do to help out the
the african savages okay as a moral
imperative and so and now
that is not it's not viewed in that
context
so some something is evolving a sense of
morality and judging what is evil and
what it isn't what what is that
wait wait wait what are you doing what's
matt well i
i never heard that explanation i always
thought it was like
look we can get them cheap
and they went and grabbed people which
makes it
immoral are you a descendant of ham your
skin is
darkened and you are cursed and so this
is in
christianity but so when does the
when does when does the moral compass
stop
because there's or is it always in flux
well
depends doesn't it that's what i'm
asking well you would hope that it's
always
evolving that it's always improving that
you know as as
the community reflects on what is good
and what is bad that we have a greater
sense you know as one gets when one ages
right or gets older
and so we see that that's clearly
immoral now and evil which you're right
they didn't see that
back in the day and also it was in the
bible you had slaves in the bible you
have slaves in the new testament and so
they not only looked at it as
uh you know kind of justifiable but
something that's in scripture and so now
with more
not only that not from my read of
scripture there is no
indictment of the possession of slaves
so well it's not even just a neutral
thing there's not even
any yeah i mean and negative statements
right right and so
the question is to your point michael
about you know how do we
discern and how do we develop i think as
an individual uh can develop a sense of
right and wrong and kind of deepen it
right as you get
more mature and understand more about
the world i think a
community can do that too right and so a
community can look at
a statue and say there's this person who
now we no longer
you know want to honor right because we
are developing our sense of morality
but if if if this is laid down by god
shouldn't it be
in eternal truth if you went to heaven
and you had
slaves and then you were like i was a
great person i had these slaves and that
was the moral thing to do
and then a hundred years later people
like you shouldn't have slaves does that
person get kicked out of heaven
that yeah yeah
[Laughter]
that's a good oh and that's that's a
very important question i mean how much
of
and i don't have an easy answer that how
much of morality is culturally
conditioned
and is also conditioned in the time that
you live and i sometimes wonder
what are the things that we are doing
today that
100 or 500 years from now will be seen
as you know
unbelievably immoral well i i sometimes
think that you know candy corn
well i think we can all agree on that
the cultural change though is not random
it's not just cultures are just bouncing
around believing different things
it's moving in a certain direction the
ark is bending towards justice thank you
thank you neil
available at fine book tours everywhere
that that is to say the moral art moral
sphere is expanding to include more
people
as equal under the law under rights
under treatment
dignity respect and so on such that um
that more and more we are tending to
think of people that are different from
us whoever that is are equal to us uh
and that's what's been changing it's
taken centuries to do it
but it's slowly gradually getting so
civil rights women's rights gay rights
and that sequence that was in that
sequence that's right that's how that
unfolds
so the so father coming out
in defending lgbtq rights is a big step
because somebody on your team that comes
out and says
we are going to treat these people
equally whatever your argument is if
god created them all equally i don't
care that's good that's part of the step
to one more step and the moral arc the
moral arc we're getting there
this is star talk live from king's
theater brooklyn new york
we are talking about the science of
morality
so michael can can science inform
or even determine human values
if that's the case that's opposite or
very different from what so many people
have learned
or been taught throughout their lives
you attend some religious service and
and your most people's understanding who
are religious
is that your morality comes from god and
so
and you're it seems like you're not even
going there you've got other
explanations for this so how
how is it that facts that drive science
can inform values which are the products
of our feelings
and of society that we create yeah so
this is the hard problem um
almost all scientists and philosophers
say you can't and they always
turn to the great philosopher david hume
who said you can't derive an ought from
an
is this is the way nature is that
doesn't mean it ought to be this way we
can change it okay
in other words scientists can describe
nature would not
offer not use science to inform how
nature ought to be that's right okay so
i would like to challenge that a little
bit in this sense
just think about say mathematics or
or physics again we'll go back to that
if you're doing your
calculations correctly there are certain
things you will find out that are more
likely to be true than other things
so say kepler discovering that planets
travel in elliptical orbits rather than
circles
given that he was doing his calculations
correctly and
planets really do travel in ellipses he
could hardly have discovered anything
else
okay so this is true in biology had
darwin not discovered
the theory of natural selection as the
mechanism of evolution
somebody else would in fact somebody
else did alfred russell wallace
and then so i i would say the same thing
with
with the moral sense what we've been
doing for centuries is discovering that
there's certain ways
of structuring a society a community of
people that live together
in that that are more harmonious to our
collective
and individual uh well-being our
our survival and flourishing as sentient
beings
you're saying we're discovering a
pre-existing yes fact
that are there in nature it's there in
our nature we desire
to be free to be autonomous to have to
be treated
equally that is for me to convince you
to be nice to me
i have to appeal to your sense that i
will be nice to you back this is the
golden rule
it is this is the kind of thing that's
really whoopee what
i i think i don't understand what you're
saying because
that means she doesn't understand well
yeah okay
because if it is in fact
morally in us because of science
to do and make these decisions why
is it that it isn't it hasn't morally
been
able we haven't morally been able to
treat
women equal to men we haven't been able
to
if it's if it's a science if it's in our
if it's in there and it's in our dna
why is this why is it so hard to do that
that's what i'm asking okay
good question yeah my answer is
is that 2017 is the best year in the
history of
human civilization for women it's never
been this good
it's got a long ways to go you about to
get
i wouldn't say that i i might
i might look that back a little bit
i'll let me you wouldn't put it in 2015
or so
i got this i got this if you were female
or if you were black and you walked into
a time machine is there any time in the
past
where you would say yeah things were
better than
than today but that but neil is that
there
is there give me a give me a year where
that was the case
i can't give you the year but i'll tell
you egypt seemed a lot more interesting
when cleopatra was running [ __ ]
okay i'm just saying
she seemed that she seemed to have it
together and
you know yeah but then i guess but like
jews wouldn't go back that's right yeah
that's right
very few jewish women would go back and
change it around
and make it work see if women ran things
we would actually i i believe
if women actually ran things
we could help men adjust to a lot of
things
typical woman
i know a typical woman would be much
nicer about it
but so let me get back to a time
that we generally think of as the
scientific revolution after the
the the scientific method was advanced
by
galileo francis bacon and the
enlightenment that generally we think of
uh in europe where science flourished
culture flourished art flourished
there were wars and things in the rest
of that but that's kind of has always
been happening
the rest of this was different and
there was great cathedral building
church building over that time
would you say that over that time there
was
moral progress yes absolutely i mean
just what about some examples
okay abolition of slavery abolition of
torture abolition of capital punishment
except for the united states uh civil
rights women's rights
gay rights these things have all
happened
go back to well okay so it begins with
the idea that
the universe is discoverable and it's
governed by
natural principles and laws that we can
understand that
starts with the physical sciences into
the biological sciences into the social
sciences the idea that
a society a political system is a system
we can study and and look at it and go
look
these systems are better than these over
here democracies
are objectively better than
dictatorships and theocracies
by every measure and this is my point
these are experiments just to be clear
objectively better would mean it spreads
happiness
more well-being survival flourishing
rights all that stuff okay our mutual
friend the late great carl sagan has a
great chapter
in the demon hunter world on these kinds
of experiments we have 50 different
states with 50 different laws
constitutions different gun control laws
different alcohol laws and so on these
are experiments that we can look and go
social experiments social experiments so
this is this is called the comparative
method
of natural experiments you can't control
the variables in a lab but we can look
at what happened
so just go back to 1970s korea so north
and south korea are divided
in the early 70s they split economically
and politically one went
super dictatorship the other liberal
democracy you can see the difference
from space
one is dark and impoverished the other
one is light and enlightened
the south koreans are five inches taller
than north koreans okay
so a liberal democracy is objectively
better than a dictatorship
that we can measure and say with
confidence and not just democracies but
all these other concepts of of like
civil rights and civil liberties just
ask the people that are affected would
you rather live in which you are treated
equally under the law or not
of course people say yes i want to be
treated equally okay when is that
it's not perfect so if our metric is it
has to be perfect
we're not there and we're never going to
be in utopia but it's better than it was
last year better than it was 20 years
ago better than a century ago
and so on your time machine over on
average on average
so so father is there uh
what do you see as the
okay whoopi what
i'm just going to say it again you know
if you go back
and trace when you're talking about
science
female scientists in galileo's time were
not
they were burned as heretics and women
which is yeah see the h word is because
i was talking to you
but but i just i i just think to myself
yeah lots of things have changed but
some things
have taken an inordinately long
time in doing and education
for people who are not wealthy
women for women i mean science and
and all of these things you all are
talking about are things that
kept women out i'm just wait wait so let
me add something to what she said now
yes i want to
back up my woman here okay if
what you guys are saying is true
it shouldn't have required centuries of
bloodshed
to get to the bits of equality that we
have today
it should be it should have flowed
naturally you
martin luther king would not have would
have had to march on washington
you wouldn't have had to have all the
women's demonstrations you wouldn't have
had to have
the gay rights movement because it would
have just been natural for people to
think of equality that way
and the fact that it has been so delayed
thousands of years of history
argues against your thesis and father
your thesis that this is somehow
deeply within us and that it is an
inevitable consequence
okay no but i yeah can i respond
okay am i did i get your back
no i and i yes i think that's i mean i
think that's
i think that's a very important question
but i also think that it is deeply
within us but it is also deeply within
us to choose the wrong thing i mean
we're also we are
i mean it's a word that's not popular
but we are sinful people in many ways
and we have
uh you know subjugated people out of it
is about power we have been selfish
we have been selfish as community
towards another community so yeah it's
taken a ridiculously long time to get to
the place of women's rights and and
african-american rights and lgbt rights
because you know we are
you know as you were saying the
beginning there are those conflicting
forces that we see
i would say on us on a small scale
within us you know you you struggle with
selfish and
and selfless as the society does um i
also think a lot of it has to do not
only with power but
we were talking about that statue of
teddy roosevelt in front of the natural
history museum who we see as other
right who is the other right and as we
understand more and more people as
as as ourselves right there's there's no
us and them there's just us
then we can come to understand what
their needs are and yeah it's
terrible it's taken so long but i think
that's a lot of that is
human nature and our own you know
terrible sinfulness but also morality is
deep in there
this book trying to put an olive branch
out between the catholic church and lgbt
community i would say most of the
nation's
resistance to the equality of that
community
if you part the curtains has religious
foundation that is absolutely right
okay so they are making a moral judgment
yes they are private lives right and so
one of the things is that what this is
what put you
on the on the [ __ ] list of the of the
right wing conservative christian right
right yeah but but in 20 years
you wouldn't be on the [ __ ] list because
no one's going to they'll all be gay
[Laughter]
an army of [ __ ] conservatives
yeah and so that and so the challenge
and so the challenge for people
uh is to be able to see uh you know in
my case in the catholic church lgbt
people not as
other anymore you know not as not as the
them but as the us
that's why you wrote this book yeah and
you know i mean part of it is this is
what this is what jesus does in the
gospels jesus is always going out to
people
on the margins right the roman
centurions margins of the day and the
martial exactly right which were
different than the margins of
of our time and he's getting you know to
use a theological term he gets [ __ ] for
it too
so and i think that
but think about think about how fast
this has happened for the gay community
versus say women african-american
slavery death penalty and so on which
took centuries to change
you know the the you know the the the
the equal
opport equal marriage you know laws and
all that changed pretty quick once that
started cascading
in other words there's kind of an
acceleration as one moral movement
uses the techniques and methods and
strategies of the previous
moral revolution because they know they
can see what works
so like when when martin luther king jr
did his uh you know
marches and so on these were calculated
to do certain things to change the laws
and subsequent generations of moral
crusaders can look and see what worked
now let's try that
it turns out violence doesn't work
almost never works
father you make an argument about a
two-way bridge could you describe that
from your book yeah so i say that the um
there are two groups there's the
institutional church which is the
hierarchy and the bishops and
anyone who works in any sort of official
capacity in the church including lay
people who would run schools women and
men
and there's the lgbt in this book it's
very sort of specific the lgbt catholic
community
and the illness is on the institutional
church to reach out to the
lgbt community because it is the
institutional church that is
marginalized the lgbt catholic
but it is a two-way bridge because the
lgbt community you know has to kind of
you know enter into a dialogue as well
you know even though
it's more difficult you know because
they're the marginalized ones and so
it's a
it's an attempt to try to build a bridge
between those two groups
uh and it frankly just to start the the
conversation and it's
it's a difficult conversation as you
know as since i'm on the [ __ ] list
but the point is you know i think i
would i would say this
you know i would say this i think your
point is a good michael that that it is
up to
see it is up to the the religious person
to to stand for the other
at least in the in the christian point
of view it is up for the the jesus
always takes the side
you know desmond tutu said that the
simplest way
god sides with the outsiders period
right and so it's actually up to
religion
which unfortunately has been used
against the outsiders you know as an
excuse right but the only time in
history that's happened
what's that sorry i said the only time
in history that's happened
well no but i mean you look at i mean
for example like you look at the
reverend dr martin luther king you know
who comes out of this
this christian tradition right and who
uses his uh his christian background
king's
mentor his his sort of role models were
gandhi
and non-violent yeah social change
because non-violence works
faster and better than violence to bring
about social change
and that itself has progressed over the
last half century so let me make one
final statement that'll
bring a heap of hate on me just because
i i don't have enough tonight
conservatives today
are more socially liberal than liberals
were in the 1950s yeah that's probably
right
yeah just think about how people talked
about jews and blacks and women in the
1950s than now yeah
so we've still we've all okay i know
it's not
we're not there yet but but but it's
it's
we've all shifted that the whole moral
zeitgeist has shifted
through a thousand different little uh
avenues
even yeah i mean today you can hook up
in a car and nobody would care in the
50s you were
judged that's right yes
if it's a kia i'm still judging
this is star talk live from king's
theater brooklyn new york
we are talking about the science of
morality
with best-selling author michael shermer
lately author of the moral
arc he's also publisher and
and uh editor i guess editor-in-chief of
skeptics magazine
i doubt it
[Laughter]
oh man i've never heard that one
[Laughter]
still enjoyable though we're with father
james martin he's a jesuit priest his
second time
on star talk we love him to death we
have a special guest appearance at
whoopi goldberg whoopi
thanks for coming out for this wow
yeah uh we got michael ian black michael
thanks yep
and also
uh eugene merman eugene
so eugene i have a one-line bio for you
in my notes here it says um you're the
voice of gene belcher in bob's burgers
and i thought surely there's more on his
resume
than that but we'll accept
the one-liner as a then i realized
this is part of the eugene merman comedy
festival so
that's a whole thing with his name so
eugene thanks for keeping comedy
i don't know whether life would be
bearable without
the the the legions of comedians you
bring to bear on all of
society's challenges thank you thank you
neil
it's it's probably safe to say we're the
real heroes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so in your book you you have a chapter
on lgbt
rights can you comment on uh if science
has
anything to say about that well okay so
first
at the very least if the science informs
us
that it's not a choice it's you're just
born that way
that tells us that condemning it as a
wrong choice is itself wrong and so that
at least gets us a step in the right
direction if we know something about
biology and embryology
and hormones and so on and and you know
so there's this great spectrum
uh in in uh you know sexual choices and
preferences and so
not choices preferences that's why we
use that word it's just how it is so
or orientation uh then we can at least
be more respectful so i mean
so in the book i talk about the witch
theory of causality if you believe that
burning
women at the stake for cavorting with
demons in the middle of the night as an
explanation for storms and diseases and
plagues then you're either insane or you
live 500 years ago
now nobody burns women as witches in the
west anyway it's
very rare elsewhere and so we've been
debunking essentially
wrong ideas mainly science you know that
that
that blacks are inferior that women
can't run
companies and countries these are wrong
ideas that
jews poison the wells or cause the
plague
or the stab in the back in the first
world war these are all wrong ideas and
we debunk them
to the point where no one even talks
about it anymore you don't even think
about it these are crazy ideas
and so no
i don't poison wells if that was the
question
so whoopi you you've had some lgbt
activism
in your day yes i have and and so
so so here is someone who has been
active and can comment on the success or
failure rate
of these efforts well what's interesting
is that
what you're saying about science and
what science knows
and has been hesitant to say
definitively this is what is this is why
you're wrong
science hasn't come out and actively
fought
the prejudice people have and in part
you're catching a lot of [ __ ] because
when people think religion
you know there are religious things you
know people keep pointing to things in
the bible saying well it says
man shall not lie with men well i always
tell people at my shows
have you read isaiah have you read the
rest of it
because one of them is you know any man
who has sex with an
animal shall be put to death but so
shall the animal
my question what did the animal do
you know what i mean anyone who curses
their parents shall be put to death yeah
half the room is gone it's
so adultery too you have yes i mean you
have
you have this idea of what is moral
and what is religiously moral and what
is scientifically moral
and trying to get the two
to reconcile seems to be difficult
because you just said as science knows
you know
it isn't a choice you are born this way
i was talking
and i explained i often get into trouble
because i say well if you believe
in the bible you believe in adam and eve
you say
well what happened god said hey adam
what's up adam's saying
i don't know i'm feeling some kind of
way that was the black god
yeah what'd it be like
[Laughter]
that's the tv black guy
very good god says what i know what's
wrong you need some company
if you believe okay what is
it adam says god says take a deep breath
this
is going to hurt goes in gets a rib
pulls it out pulls it out of the man
atom
and structures a female
which says to me that god
if you believe in god and you believe in
the bible
gave us a sexual duality
in us so if you believe in god
this is god-given this is god-given
so i say this in my shows
and people freak out they don't they say
that's not what god
that's not god so i don't
know how to get both hands
to stand up for community
that desperately needs both your health
yeah
very important point thank you
just to sort of still hit that but move
it a little further
it's not only the lgbt community
and you know the woman within the man
the man within the woman
there's also lots of dialogue
about whether contraception
is immoral especially from the catholic
church
and also abortion now here's what's
interesting to me i have
conversations with my wife about this
often so you have
um generally the people who are
anti-abortion
if you part the curtains there's a
religious foundation for their argument
but in principle you could make a
a just a non-killing another human
argument
without reference to god because thou
shalt not kill is
the one of the ten commandments that's
made it into
secular law so the rest nobody really
well stealing feelings yeah sure but
graven images and stuff right yeah yeah
that's that's it was very in its day
yeah that was a thing but just to be
clear i'm currently having
sex with my neighbor's wife that's cool
legally right
[Applause]
so so uh so what i what i want to
understand here is there's a moral
judgment placed
coming from a religious community on
abortion
yet one can say you are killing a living
human being whether or not it's yet
sentient
or or viable
and you can say um
that the woman's body is her own so all
of these
for her to choose so so all of these
have arguments some of them more
religiously conceived than others
can you now project into the future
where morality will land on that
spectrum well
we're about to go to the break and neil
wants to resolve the abortion issue
yes in 30 seconds or less are you can
you invoke are you going to evoke
science
well you can invoke okay you can you can
look at the trends
which has been more and more toward the
autonomy and liberty of
individuals to make their own decisions
so
the abortion case is a special one in
this case because
you know the fetus is at least a
potential human but
a higher moral principle is that the
women should be free to choose
because of a whole host of historical
reasons and that
there's certain moral values that are
higher than others but you're making a
moral judgment by saying
uh the the woman has the higher moral
principle yeah well so what i'm invoking
is is the historical tendency
for uh liberal democracies to give more
people more rights
in more areas of life over time and so
so again we're back to the ark the arc
so women having reproductive control
over their
uh choices uh is a step in the right
direction because for thousands of years
men have lorded it over women to make
that choice for them and
that is a kind of slavery it's kind of
controlling somebody else
so moving away from that now
you know admittedly the abortion issues
complicate you know you can be against
abortion and pro-choice
you can say i'm not gonna do it but i
recognize your
uh free freedom to choose what you want
to do
well that's that's the that's the gay
marriage issue so if you don't like
gay marriage then just don't get gay
marriage that's right it's not
it's not a requirement kind of yeah not
requiring it of you
for this to be to be the case um
did you just kill my joke
[Laughter]
if you don't believe in gay marriage
don't marry a gay
person that's the joke oh
yeah that is how you should have phrased
it neil
[Laughter]
um so so here's here's a point
to that to those issues okay um
religion is clearly bringing a
pre-existing
um foundation of moral judgment
to these issues clearly okay
recognizing father as you've said
candidly that it can evolve as we go
forward
by discussion or analysis or whatever if
science
up till now you you've mentioned science
only in the context of informing
people about how they might make a
decision but at no time are you saying
that the science itself is saying what
is moral well i am saying that actually
i haven't quite gotten you haven't said
it like explicitly
so if i ask you if science has the power
to
shape morals should it
well yes because wouldn't that then
carry
in just the way different religions
carry in
to this table when they carry in maybe
the biases or preconceptions
of the scientific community at that time
go back when was the tuskegee experiment
the 40s in the 1940s 30s medical doctors
giving
out not treating
syphilis when they could have leading
the men black men to believe that they
were getting medication
so that they can study the progress of
the disease yet not telling them
this is like a moral failure of the
medical community who were conducting a
scientific experiment but isn't that
partially because the moral failure was
not
of the scientists but of the time
because they
these people these men were not seen as
human beings
and that's
but if it's already in you why don't why
why didn't it become a moral
decision well because again we have our
the the inner demons and the better
angels or the sinful nature there's that
other side
where like as you put it we can get them
cheap well there's plenty of people that
are willing to to
to go along with that and rationalize it
with biblical arguments or
we're saving their souls for
christianity or whatever
uh and but we don't think like that
anymore because we've debunked this idea
that
they actually like being slaves no they
don't you're wrong about that
boom now sometimes you got to fight you
don't get to pass the laws fight the
wars whatever
but once you get there what are the
chances okay slavery is illegal in every
country
in the world all 192 countries what are
the chances that any of those countries
would bring it back as a legal
institution
no no they have you i'm i i don't even
want to tell you this but you would be
shocked to find out
how many countries are engaged
in slavery so the point here is
there's whatever the country says and
then there's yeah what's happening yes
that's right
you got people that eat bad people they
just want to exploit people
the point is having a law first and then
enforce the law have a
these are mostly in countries where the
governments are weak or corrupt and they
can't enforce their
laws so anyway a lot of this is is there
a place
science should just stay out of in the
moral
fiber and i might even ask the same of
religion
if you have 10 different religions
giving you 10 different moral
interpretations of conduct
maybe none of them should be listened to
and we go to a secular
analysis of it yeah i mean i think
there's
i think there are plenty of places i
mean we have separation of church and
state you know thank god
in this country there are plenty of
places i mean truly
there are plenty of places where you
know religion uh you know you can bring
you are a moral person who
who are who is uh sort of informed by
your religion
but there are plenty of times when
religion does not need to be explicitly
applied to a particular situation
absolutely and we have also seen times
when religion has been applied you know
unjustly you know or immorally
but i would say i mean i think the lgbt
case is a good one in terms of how
science informs us so this idea that
which we now discard i think most you
know reputable psychologists and
psychiatrists
uh that that it's a choice right so
since people
understand it as something that you're
born you know as lady gaga says born
that way
right um yeah no it's true but she said
born
this way thank you well um not that way
this way i'm 56 so yeah
um that you know just for
[Laughter]
that you know we understand that it is
not uh which we used to think many
people used to think was a
a choice and therefore a moral choice
right and so therefore the person who
chose that was immoral
and bad and so needed to be condemned
and so now i mean i think you're seeing
this
diminution of people you know who
actually think that and the majority
understand not only through
through their own experience with their
families and people coming out but thank
god
science which actually i think is going
to eradicate
a lot of that prejudice you know or at
least at least most of it that says that
this is some sort of choice and thank
god
so i mean in a sense that's where
science can really inform
i think that's a great case where
science can really inform and we can see
it in a lifetime a moral choice can i
ask another very unfunny question
that's sort of what i do
both i i feel like what both of you are
saying
uh is that
in terms of how morality developed it
seems like it has to do with
scarcity of resources that in order to
propagate and make our species survive
et cetera et cetera et cetera we need to
vote co-op
we need to uh cooperate um and what
you're saying or what i understand
morality to originate in the in in
biblical writings
is that it had to do with a similar
thing keeping the keeping the tribe safe
keeping people safe
learning how to cooperate for
propagation
and uh and essentially harmony doesn't
there come a point
that's not what he said but keep going
i'm not listening to what he said
doesn't there come a point if everybody
is harmonious and cooperating that
doesn't then
the uh doesn't resources become more
scarce and doesn't that make us actually
more likely to tip into
uh entropy uh
leading us back into the second law of
thermodynamics
back to the physicist yeah
isn't it too soon to say that you know
world war ii was 60 years ago that's
that's less than an eye blink
and it was that was the most devastating
war in human history right
so who are we to say that in 10 years
you know it's not going to happen again
i mean there's a lot of people think
we're going to war with china
they got a billion people there that's
going to suck
it's not first of all how are they going
to get here
who the chinese zeppelins
billions just like people feared in 1910
i do want to make one one small point
even if it turned out
that being gay was a choice
it's still not okay to oppress gay
people because there's a higher moral
principle
that you have autonomy and freedom over
your body to choose whatever you want if
no one else is harmed
okay so to that point i'm going to add
punctuation i'm going to end this
segment
uh if you hadn't made that point i would
have
coming out of this segment because
there's a point where
and if you hadn't i would have
i think this is the easiest case to say
this about
but there are probably other cases for
which this applies there are times where
i would declare that the science
is irrelevant i was asked this from a
magazine
that served the gay community they said
what's your stand
on whether science
shows that it is a choice or
or or inbred and i said
it doesn't matter what the science says
we live in a
free country at least we tell ourselves
we live in a
free country and for me
what consenting adults do is an
expression of what it means
to live in a free country no matter
whether science says
that that's your choice or not so you
should not be waiting around for that
scientific result
and then grabbing it and putting it
forward if it says it's not a choice
because if the science happened to say
it is a choice
then you're going to have to reject the
science and say you need it on
the principles of the founding fathers
of this country
so that would be a case where if it's
about human freedom
it's not about the science it's about
what we choose as a secular society
but do we only live in a secular society
say what i said but that would be so if
we only lived in a secular
society
you know that ends our second segment of
star talk live
welcome back star talk live
king senator brooklyn
we're going to try to see if we can
expand the moral sphere
of this and so let me ask you
father would you say that religion on
the whole
has helped hindered or
been neutral to this arc of moral
progress
that that michael talks about well i
would say i'm this is going to sound
very jesuitical
um but that's a word that is a word
is oh i like it i'm using it tomorrow
[Laughter]
you know but it depends do you mean the
way that uh
people have actually lived religion or
do you mean actual religion i mean
that's like that gandhi quote about
right i i'd love to meet a christian one
day um i think people who
i think people who really live religious
lives you know someone like francis of
assisi or saying our day someone like
pope francis you know does
uh change the world for the good but
there are other people who have used
religion
uh you know just as evilly uh in general
i would say that uh
religion has been a moderating influence
on some of our
our worst tendencies our selfish
tendencies the golden rule for example
but i would also say that
you know religion has been used to
subjugate people and religious wars in
particular
uh you know religion versus religion has
actually led to you know great
suffering i mean for example you know
the the the foundations of a lot of
anti-semitism in
in europe you know which led to the
holocaust were religiously based
right and so it's a very complex
question um and and once again it
depends
what you mean by religion and and who
you're talking about
and how they live out their religion so
uh is there some sort of moral place
you can see us heading towards again i'm
on this arc
concept here uh in 10 years something
going on now that you say
religion will be a good force in that
and in 10 years that'll
that'll be oh yeah i mean i i mean i
know
i'm you know a little biased but
i think that to be very specific i think
that pope francis's
shift uh to a church that is more
focused
on mercy and compassion i mean that is
his constant theme
right and he's supposed to blame and
just well yeah and he has said
specifically uh i think that we have
been talking too much about
sexual morality right and i think in a
sense you know everybody knows what you
know that the church teaches and so i
want to bring us back to the
the basics which is more mercy
compassion and
desire for uh justice for the poor and i
think
uh you know that if people actually put
that into action you know we'll be a lot
better off and he's not afraid to
to shake things up the question is again
and to your point and i know it
you know you've raised this a couple
times the question is do we accept that
or not
i mean do do we as as individuals accept
you know the migrants and refugees have
as much place
uh you know as anyone on the stage does
right i mean they're individuals who are
who are desirous of
something good or do we individually and
as a community and as a nation reject
that
right so i mean that that's that's the
difficult thing because we are sinful
and selfish and we have to work against
those things
do you agree with i mean i can't see how
you do but father do you agree that the
higher moral principle
in the abortion debate is that women
have autonomy versus
uh an un
i mean that is a very you know i thought
we left abortion
but but look it's gonna get this is
gonna get cut out anyway but
yeah you're both you're both moral
authorities you're from a scientific
point of view you from religious point
of view i assume you both feel like you
can claim the higher moral principle
from your point of view
so how does a layman like me go
yeah he's right or he's right or in
whoopi's case well but i think i think
that's where your conscience comes in
i mean it's not simply no no i know that
old thing
uh you know it's not it's not simply i
mean in a sense
you know it's not simply sort of an
imposition of rules from the outside
it's also your own conscience i mean you
know one of the great things about the
church that people i think forget about
is
is this this idea of the primacy of your
conscience you know where
as as one church document says you know
god's voice resounds in you right and so
so there's that too and it's i mean
because we don't and this is one of the
things that pope francis is trying to
remind us of you know life is not about
black and white laws right uh there are
black and white laws in some cases yes
or no laws but in most cases you know
our lives are very gray
and so it's it's a development of the
conscience and the development for the
christian
i mean i'm sorry to focus on
christianity so much on jesus and an
encounter with jesus
and seeing and noticing what he does and
how he treats people and so one one one
moves from that
the degree to which you agree with pope
francis
may certainly be genuine but we should
be reminded that he is your boss
that's right clear about that um
i have a few comments to make on
religion um and i'm reminded of
winston churchill's comment about
americans you can always count on
americans to do the right thing
after they've tried everything else and
and
religion do the right thing eventually
eventually
one of those yeah okay that was that was
spike lee and you can't
really do the right thing yeah oh yeah
religions do come around
slowly and so when the father talks
about it
we change our conscience it's religion
is almost always lag
behind by a decade or so or two
from the culture that's already making
the shift just think about interracial
marriage
remember when that was a thing yeah me
neither in 1967
it was illegal in the united states it
was illegal
and now it's not no one even talks about
it anymore and in in 1959 a poll showed
that 96 percent of americans were
against
interracial marriage now they don't even
ask the question anymore
religions oppo oh they do okay well
religions opposed interracial marriage
now they don't what happened the culture
shifted
and and so the wave is like this and
religion is kind of coming up behind the
wave
the surfer that catches it after it's
already broke that's my
metaphor he lives in a surfing community
now yeah
so is it is it are we actually talking
about
morality or are we actually talking
about
empathy because they're i think they're
to go together
no i'm not i don't know if they do
that's why i'm asking
because i think when you ask the
question in 10 years
i think depending on how you educate
your children i grew up with
trick-or-treat for unicef
and because i grew up with
trick-or-treat for unicef and the
chocolate bars
that we sold we were told this was
helping
children like us around the world you
were selling chocolate bars to other
children on halloween that's important
no no no that's immoral
but when i was a kid i went to catholic
school
and so we would have these drives to
raise money for the school and
also to raise money for other
communities and you bring home these few
pennies and that was your bit
and you well you know if you did it for
halloween you got a lot of money
got those pennies but see people don't
give pennies anymore
but we felt we were we had some
hand in making the world better and so
i i don't know if we thought of it as
being moral
we just thought of it as doing the right
thing to help the world so
do we actually just sort of whittle this
down to
empathy that's a great question let me
broaden it by asking
do you teach this in schools can you
teach morality in schools
even if it's this little exercise of of
a of a unicef collection i think it
starts with
parents siblings peers and so on it gets
inculcated in culture most of the
kinds of shifts we've been talking about
have come from the
more from the bottom up than the top
down yes you do need the laws passed
sometimes you need the military to go in
but most of the time it's just
our language changes if you look at
literature from the 30s versus the 50s
versus the 90s
and so on comic books films novels
all of it shifts the words you use the
way you describe
characters and all that uh just that
moment when ellen says on that show you
know into the microphone i'm gay or
whatever
where she said well that was a big step
now you know 10 years later seinfeld
makes a joke about you know not that
there's anything wrong with it
and now we laugh about it and now it's
just kind of commonplace
you know gay whatever dude who cares and
that's how it kind of just slows it
happens slow enough you don't really
notice it
and the other problem is the media only
covers the bad stuff
so for every act of violence school
shootings you see on
on tv there's 10 000 acts of kindness
every day that go unreported
so so going forward should
the religious leaders the religious
community
work with scientists to shape to to
shape this moral arc
and it's one thing to say religion is
lagged a decade behind or more
but religion has huge influence in the
western world especially in the united
states
so it's not something that should be
discounted
in its role in shaping society so are
there
is there your you or your counterparts
reaching out i know carl sagan did
carl sagan would have meetings with
religious leaders just to talk about
saving the world and how can that best
be accomplished so
uh i have to presume father that
your your very presence on the stage is
a step in that direction
to reach for scientists to find out what
we're thinking and how and why
yeah that book was almost called who
cares
you're gay dude are you suggesting might
there be a future
of collaboration with what scientists
think uh
philosophers are thinking well yeah i
would think i mean
there already is i mean in most uh sort
of forward-thinking churches and
there is there's no fear and there
should be no fear of science well i mean
they're they're both geared towards the
truth basically and sort of unearthing
the truth and helping us
understand things better and understand
the world better so the latest
encyclical
uh the the holy father uh spoke
at length about climate change no of
course right and you know it's
interesting
of course did you say like that oh no i
know
why they're course for him but you know
he's a religious leader he is awesome
to talk about he is also a scientist he
was a chemist uh you know as a jesuit he
studied chemistry and taught chemistry
yes herrera for chemists
um and so you know and and i think
i think this is i think this uh the
encyclical laudato c which talks about
climate change and the economy and the
and the the connection between the
effects of the disproportionate effects
of climate change on the poor i mean he
links those things
he uses not only you know science
science but economics right in
terms of helping us understand the world
so there i think that's a really great
example of a way that
uh the church or a church can use things
like science
uh climate change economics to help us
understand
what is i think at heart a moral
document it was funny i was uh
on this panel with uh uh cardinal
turkson
um who was a uh cardinal from ghana and
he was the one in charge of the
uh encyclical la dato c and he said you
know what he said this is not a
an encyclical about uh the climate it is
this is a social encyclical
it is about encyclical about society
right and about our culture and so
you're that's a great example of how
those two things can be uh brought
together and we have nothing to fear
from that nor should we i mean there's
some people who do
but we shouldn't at least once a week i
ask myself because as i see the the
the landscape shifting under our feet
particularly if you're old fogies you
say
those young whippersnappers they you
know i don't want to be
that guy so i'm trying to stay with it
as things shift
and my kids are keeping me in touch uh
so i ask myself
i i pose to my kids i say what do you
think you're doing today where your kids
will say
mommy daddy you are so out of it and
so i came up with one i think i came up
with one i would say
uh there's at least a dozen or more
sports in the olympics
that should not be segregated by gender
like
archery and shooting and badminton
and uh so but they are still segregated
i think there's a day when
all these attentions we focus on
competitive sports even
even why women's tennis why why don't
they play the same number of sets as men
they're just as fit
they can last just as long it's just so
ridiculous right i've forgotten about
that right they play
a three sets instead of five right right
right so there's things like that that
no one is focusing on yet
but it is a difference in that case
between men and women
built into baked into society on a level
that we're not even recognizing
because maybe the too many other more
important things we've got that are
distracting us but you know you can say
i think that's a great example you can
see the shift in how we look at football
right now in terms of the brain injuries
right and and what that does to to
people who play and maybe in a couple
years we'll say
how could we have allowed people to play
in that particular way football if it
was hurting their brains it wasn't that
a form of
exploitation of those people
particularly those young men right so i
yeah i agree
and i think we have to start thinking
about those things now
father if we uh create
a sentient robot
is it immoral to kill it oh my gosh
okay that's the neck that's the next
papal encyclical i guess right is that
wow uh can we talk about the eclipse
instead
[Laughter]
well yes yes yes
data's a person personhood is what we're
talking sentence leads to personhood
which leads to rights it's murder
so who will judge that it's sentient
i'll do it
okay if i pulled you from 50 years ago
from 20 years ago
and i just had you have a conversation
with siri you would say that my device
was sent in
and if i took a sledgehammer to it you
would then object
yeah i don't know what today is thinking
seriously
that's right we have a little ways to go
before this happens so now is the time
to be thinking about
how should the law deal with that same
with animals you know higher primates
and so on
you know the and that's why are your
value judging them
well the criteria yes yes you value
adjusted yes
okay yes yes it's not higher or lower
they're all
around today evolve from the beginning
of the family tree that's right okay yep
yes but i eat plants
and some meat yeah but not much
just like what like uh just like dumb
ducks
[Laughter]
so so uh a subset of the vegetarian
community sees
eating animals as immoral not just
something for health or environment or
or whatever do you see that as no yeah
and i i've as you were talking i was
thinking i can imagine
i don't know but i can imagine in 50
years people looking back and saying
i cannot believe people ate those
animals i cannot believe they killed
them and raised them
you know if we yeah i mean i can see
that um i
i'm not a vegetarian but i can totally
understand how someone could feel that
and i could understand in 50 years how
that becomes law
let's not predict something so horrible
why am i going to be dead you don't
you don't know me i could live to be
120.
yeah that's the plan there is that
generation who will be born
where they will never die because they
will always be available for the next
thing that will prolong life yeah
isn't that immoral to live forever
if you're if you're living on a planet
with limited resources no no you
you explore outer space
resources are unlimited let me ask each
of you just for some
parting thoughts we'll wrap this up
before we go to q a
um uh why don't we end on on on the
father let's let's
really you don't think that
i mean he'll be something about like
love it up lovers
but then i'll be like in here as i've
studied over the generations
okay what do you have for us just give
me some summative thoughts
you can even um reflect on what might
what would morality look like in a
hundred years so is this jerry's final
moment
yeah yeah okay yes what will morality
look like in a hundred years
there will be i think unless we
destroy ourselves uh optimistic
say it again are you optimistic i am i
think that it will be largely better i
do think that overall
uh things get better and better i i
think that football will either be
significantly more violent or gone
[Laughter]
that's basically it but i think overall
yeah i think it'll it'll be better
hopefully they'll people still eat fish
jesus
come on that's why i didn't meet anyway
and he did
michael well uh i've rarely been as
frustrated in the conversation
conversation as i have been in this one
i think they're both
full of [ __ ] i i think
i think everything that you're saying is
is great and and
and scientifically based and i think
everything you're saying is great
uh and i think that one nuclear bomb
uh or one crazy person obviates all of
it and it doesn't
matter uh what you're what you're saying
that's the the
power in the hands of those who are
immoral yeah but i also think renders
moot
the statements of morality who are yeah
nothing inevitable about this i didn't
call on you yet okay all right so
all right so so you you so you're not
optimistic about it it's not that i'm
not optimistic but i don't think
i don't i don't feel like we've come any
closer to solving the question of
morality
in this conversation but you know i was
mostly thinking about jokes the whole
time
so agreed it's not michael it's it's not
inevitable the whole thing could go
south absolutely
the south that's a value judgment all
the more reason that to keep
keep working you pass moral judgment on
the south
in that sentence sorry
things that go north really fast
we end up in canada because of global
warming yeah yeah then they're going to
build that wall and make us pay for it
anyway so
um the canadians building the wall
making us faithful you know it's three
steps forward two steps back you know we
have to keep chipping away at it and
and working at it um and so and in part
science and technology is part of the
solution
synthetic meat we are getting there
within a few decades
you we won't need factory farms anymore
you can just grow it
and and and and make it a profitable
thing for companies and we'll have
burgers and steaks that are just
as marbled and tasty and oh boy but
isn't there also the argument that
i know but the cows will go extinct if
we do that the cows will go extinct if
we do that or close
um well unless you can make cows your
pets that's that's
the only place you'll find cows is in
india yeah right so isn't that likely
so the cow only exists for that purpose
they still use them for milk i guess
yeah yeah so one platter yeah and butter
yeah milk butter cheese
all milk products right yeah yeah so
technology
and then i agree uh neil i think in the
last chapter the moral arc i speculated
on
us becoming a multi-planetary
spacefaring civilization
in which there's no more nation-states
either nation-states is
is a temporary stage in human history
cities are the oldest structures we have
the oldest
collective system organizations we have
there are cities that are thousands of
years old there are
no nations that are thousands of years
old the borders change these will come
and go once you just open the borders up
and let people do whatever they want to
do
then there'll be more freedom and
autonomy and this will reduce the
chances of
nuclear war and things like that so i'm
optimistic
optimistic okay uh and just one note uh
in martin luther king's i have a dream
speech
there's a very significant moment where
he speaks of the moral arc
bending towards righteousness so justice
yes justice
bends towards justice uh whoops yeah
what you got for us i know you got
something don't i don't know what i got
free you know i
i i think that it's it is incumbent upon
us
all as individuals to decide who we are
morally whether you're whether it's
inbred and you
or you know these are these are things
that come to you because of your
experiences what you learn what you know
who's taught you
what you believe what you've come to
believe and i think that those are
important things and
you can put it in science and you can
put it in god and whatever it is
it's still your it's still you
you have to decide morally what
and who you're gonna be and
you know you can blame it on god or
blame it on science but
when it comes down to it it's it's your
choice
i think but that's just me
i smoke too much weed
the jesuit james what do you have for us
uh
i smoke just as much brother that's why
they put us together
uh not recently though no i mean i would
agree you know i would i would
uh agree with that and say uh you know
it's up to the individual i would also
say it's up to us as a community
and so in terms of where we're going i
i'll try down on a positive note but i
think that the last
two years have made me not optimistic uh
the last two years i think that
at least in the united states that we've
gotten angrier and more divided and more
coarsened
and i think you could make the argument
worldwide too in general
but i would say that i'm as a christian
i'm hopeful
uh but it really it it's it's up to us i
mean it is
it is a choice i mean and it is a moral
choice uh whether or not we're going to
um
you know be generous or not so i'm i'm
not not optimistic but i remain hopeful
so let me i'd like to offer a system
i i'm an astrophysicist so that's the
lens through which i view the world
for better or for worse uh a
bit of this that we lost a little bit
track of from the beginning
was the sense of cooperation and how
morality
feeds into the survival
of a community and not only the survival
but whether or not it thrives
and so when i think of
the reasons people have fought wars uh
many of them if not most have been
access to limited resources
many other wars fought on the premise of
one religion versus another when you
part the curtains
again it's access to resources either
natural resources or land itself so
when i think of space space in fact
has unlimited resources there are
ingredients on earth called
rare earth elements it's an entire row
of the periodic table
that are fundamental to modern
electronics and
most of those are in china and so
that's kind of interesting so that's a
limited resources by the way there are
asteroids
that are primarily made of metal
that have an abundance of rare earth
elements an abundance of iridium
platinum
gold silver copper
so in the future let's go 100 years
a thousand years into the future it's
possible that we can remove
war over limited resources we can remove
that incentive entirely if we have
access to the unlimited resources
of space not only mineral resources but
energy resources wars have been fought
over energy and so when i see this
i add to this fact that
the hubble telescope the most
productive scientific instrument there
ever was
responsible for 20 000
research papers with collaborators
in every country in which you find an
astrophysicist
wait what word did i use collaborators
do you know the international space
station is the greatest
collaboration of nations outside of the
waging of war
that there ever was
the olympics and the world cup are a
distant second and third
to that the scientific community and
especially astrophysicists
because our targets of interest are up
there and up there is not divided
by national boundary or religion or by
who's in charge
up there is space and it's over
everybody's head and so when we study
the universe i'll pull out a telescope i
look here somebody in another country
also looks at that object and we compare
notes
we are scientific colleagues we publish
papers together
it may be that the future of morality
is rolled up in what it takes to get
along
and what i know firsthand
is that when you do science you get
along
you get along because the object of your
affection
sits outside of ourselves it's a higher
purpose a higher goal to understand
the nature of this universe in which we
live
so i foresee in the centuries to come
if space becomes accessible to us
i see a time where we will only know
peace and look back at a time when
people killed one another
because of our differences and we said
my gosh
how could that have ever happened
because today we celebrate one another
because of our differences and that is a
cosmic
perspective coming to you from star talk
join me in thanking
father james martin whoopi goldberg
shermer michael ian black
eugene murman the eugene merman comedy
festival
this has been star talk we have been
live
at the kings theater in brooklyn and
you've been
an amazing audience thank you all and
good night
[Applause]
[Music]
before we go i just want to thank wix
from simple landing pages to complex
professional websites wix has you
covered no need to hire a web developer
if i was able to build this for star
talk certainly you can build your site
with wix
the editor gives you full design freedom
freedom
it's like that that was my braveheart
wix thing oh never mind they have apps
that let you grow your business they
have
unlimited fonts everything just works
it's like magic
no it's like science head to the link in
the description
and start your site today that's wix.com
go slash star talk
you